hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar single
sail antibody
discovery using islands of automation i
am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by beckmann culture
life sciences
to learn more please visit beckman.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speakers
paul anderson
senior research scientist at the lilly
biotechnology center
in san diego california for a complete
biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
paul you may now begin your presentation
welcome
okay well thank you for the introduction
uh my name is paul anderson
and i'm uh proud to present the work
that we've been doing at lilly for the
last several years in
automating a single cell process used
for biologics discovery
specifically antibody discovery i joined
lilly
two years ago so a lot of the work i'm
sharing today
is the work of a fairly large group of
people and
you know some of the people that helped
make this presentation and then had a
major role
in in developing these systems are my
co-authors mike cohen melissa crisp and
tom tujek
so i just want to thank them for the
opportunity to share share their work
and the the group's work
today with everybody so i'm going to
dive in to
talk about the process that we're
automating here
we have several discovery antibody
discovery platforms at lily
and then one specifically i'm going to
touch on today is
um immunization based
platform using single b cells
and going through a series of automated
platforms to generate lead molecules
we have several other platforms as i
mentioned that will
are orthogonal to this approach that we
use for
antibody discovery as well so this is
the the main process i'm going to be
talking about is
this single b cell application
but keep in mind a lot of these systems
are used in different aspects of
other biologists discovery efforts and
so
this topic this presentation is really
just honing in on this application here
so we have several platforms i'm going
to discuss
throughout this process and these are
really all tied together with
a lims infrastructure so we
are working on collecting information
from each of these platforms in the form
of data
as well as sample tracking and so really
one of the overarching themes here is
the software side of the of the process
where we're
capturing a significant amount of data
whether it be
purification amounts from dna or
purified material
amounts from expressed antibodies data
and associated with titers
and a significant amount of screening
results toward the end of the process
and what we're trying to hand over is
really a data package so our project
teams can make informed decisions and
triage
down to lead molecules as fast as
possible
so our process this particular process
starts with the immunization based
strategy as i mentioned so that could
start with
mice or a variety of different host host
organisms
or host species in this example we're
using a
mouse model and so we would immunize
that mouse with the antigen of interest
and then once we have sufficient serum
titer
we would isolate the b cells and use a
back sorter to dispense
antigen dispense antigen binding b
cells into 96 well plates and so
we typically start with roughly 20 96
well plates so the process i'm going to
talk about here usually it's about 20
96 well plates so about 2 000 single b
cells will go into this process
as this first pass the several projects
where we go through multiple passes
several immunization strategies and so
they grow
significantly larger in size
so first system we'll talk about is uh
what we call the film barcode system we
developed with beckman
and this was essentially a automated
liquid handler
with a series of other uh third-party
devices on there such as
cytomat a labeler a sealer we added a
balance recently
and really this system is designed to
add reagents to plates
barcode or label those plates seal them
up and for
to feed several platforms throughout our
process
with the the case of where we're sorting
cells
into plates we typically are using those
plates
are created on here with cell sore
buffer and sealed up and stored in a
chilled manner
until we're ready to sort cells into
them then once we sort cells into these
96 well plates
they come back onto this platform when
our scientists are ready to process them
and then they are consolidated into 3d
4-well pcr plates
so the the next system i'm going to talk
about where a lot of our molecular
biology takes place
this system feeds out as well adding uh
different pcr max stir mixes to a
variety of
three to four pcr plates
and so the plates come off of here
they've been consolidated into 3d floral
plates and they would come to
a what we call a molecular cloning
system also developed with beckman
and so on this system i'm going to touch
on some of the usual suspects of
instruments that you'll see
on several of the systems coming up and
so that would be
a plate lock and x peel and those are
for sealing and peeling of plates
as well as a v spin as center fusion so
that is typically to
to eliminate bubbles and pull samples to
the bottom of a well
and there's several cytomats on all our
systems so we have an ambient sediment
on this system as well as a
chilled cytomat so as we go through the
presentation i'm really going to try to
touch on
what makes each of these systems unique
in their own
right so the molecular biology of the
medical cloning system
the kind of special sauce on this guy is
the
bank of automated thermal cyclers that
you can see in the top
so there's a stack three stacks of four
thermocyclers so bank of 12 thermos
automated thermocyclers on the system
and this is what we use to carry out a
series of pcr reactions on here where we
start with the single b
cell sorted into each plate we split it
to heavy light chain
and assemble it into our our vector of
interest so the output of this system is
going to be
a heavy and light a set of heavy chain
plates and a set of light chain plates
uh assembled with the antibody gene of
interest
the first qc step in our process
incorporates
on the top left here you see an ati
fragment analyzer so we cherry pick
samples
after the second round of pcr and this
really
we run these on the fragment analyzer
and this lets us
get some insight as to are we chopping
out the fragment of interest and isn't
it the right size
so this is usually we have a fairly high
success rate of this but if there's
anything going wrong with our
master mixes or anything went south in
the sorting side of things this is where
we would typically catch
our problems and so as you come off of
this system we have
our heavy and light chain dna we go into
a semi-semi-automated
uh e-coli transformation step and so we
in a three-four ml manner do a
transformation into confidence cells
let that sit for a bit and then transfer
those into 96-foot deep well plates with
lb broth and those will sit in shaking
incubators overnight
and after that incubation overnight we
pell at the cells
we center fusion pellet the cells and
decant them and seal them and store them
at minus 20 degrees until we're ready to
do our plasma purification
so the the next part is uh
we built a new a recent system to do our
plasma base purification
and we are using the 96 turbo kit from
kaiogen
and so what you see here in the top left
is the e coli pellet block
we have to dispense a few different
reagents to resuspend lyse and
neutralize
the e coli and then we
transfer though that material into a
lysate clearance filter plate
and samples go through that to clean up
the
the garbage that's in those samples
that's kind of snotty
viscous material and it gets eluded into
a dna binding filter plate
you pull samples through that filter
plate dna binds to the membrane
do a couple rounds of washing and then
elution to to purify your pla to do your
plasma purification
so as we approach automating this their
our manual workflow involves vacuum
manifolds
and there after this last wash step we
would do
a centrifugation step to really give a
hard spin to these filter plates to get
rid of any
residual wash buffer before we do our
illusion
automated vacuum manifolds are quite
common
but there are significant drawbacks when
you have
samples that could be if you have
certain wells that don't have samples
the vacuum's going to pull through the
path of least resistance
if you have other wells where uh either
slow or
clogged a bit then those tend to not get
pulled through once you have swells
around them that get pulled through the
vacuum
the ones that are clogged or running
slower tend to be more and more
difficult to get
to pull to be able to pull through the
filter plates and so we
in talking with back when we had
explored
some other options with how to proceed
with
handling filter plate based
purifications
and so we had the idea in
to explore positive pressure devices so
we we had this discussion with beckman
they talked about some positive pressure
devices and then we started looking into
it more and found several options on the
market
and so we brought a few different
devices in that i'll talk about on the
next slide
but to just give you a little bit of a
background on what these devices are and
how they different
how they differentiate themselves from
vacuum and centrifugation
the way they they work is pulling in
house air it could be a gas nitrogen or
a different type of
gas into a pressure reservoir so you
have a high pressure side on the
reservoir
and it uses a flow restrictor and this
is essentially software controlled
to open up small holes
and let some of that gas or air through
and so what the nice thing about this
you're essentially pushing samples
through a filter plate
and whether you have an empty well or a
well that's completely clogged
since you have a large pressure
differential across the restrictor
you have the same amount of pressure
being applied to every well
so whether it's empty sample or a
clogged sample
you don't have those wells impacting the
nearby wells or adjacent wells
and so it's a very nice consistent
flow rate across the plate which is
highly desirable
the other thing is essentially to get
into these positive pressure devices
you're stacking and unstacking labware
and so that's a big benefit as well
because that's a fairly simple mechanism
to automate
so while vacuum is very inexpensive and
and easy to automate it it has some
some quality and reliability issues that
we would be concerned about
and so the centrifugation method you do
get even flow across all samples
but is a bit more challenging to
automate stacking and stacking
and the waste associated with with
plates
going in and out of the center fusion so
that that was a bit more of a
a red flag for the centrifuge based uh
method of handling filter plates whereas
positive pressure
it's a bit more expensive i mean
significantly more expensive in the
vacuum kind of on par with center f
automated centrifuges
but it's very fast easily automated and
the flow control is
is very good and so we
opted to explore this route a bit
further
what we did find in our due diligence is
that the
this is essentially someone this is very
new for most vendors and so the ones
that we reached out to
they were just starting to automate
these types of devices and so we brought
in three devices from three different
vendors
and what i'm showing you on the top
right here is
in blue our heavy chain dna and red are
light chain dna
and so we have control samples which
would be done
manually using our vacuum
incentivization
workflow and then all three devices
performed well in our hands and so
you can see there's a bit of a bump in
constant dna concentration with a heavy
chain and a significant
increase in dna concentration with the
light chain plates
this was a i would throw out the
disclaimer that this was
a fairly quick and dirty experiment
using these three different devices
not a lot of optimization done to really
dial in flow rates and dial in other
conditions uh
related to these devices so as a first
pass
in some early data we were very pleased
and
encouraged to explore this technology
further
what we did as well i mentioned in the
first system we
have automated balance on there and
you'll see that throughout the
systems i'm going to talk about we
weighed the filter plates before and
after each of the liquid handling steps
and so to explain the higher
concentration on here
what we think is happening is after you
do your last
wash step when you are pulling that
through a vacuum
and then going to a centrifuge to spin
out as much residual
wash buffer as possible there was
based on gravimetric results more wash
buffer left
on the filter plate than when we were
using the positive pressure devices
so we believe that we were effectively
eliminating pushing through more wash
buffer more residual wash buffer
on the positive pressure devices and
then when you go to your illusion you've
reduced
that residual wash buffer more
effectively on the positive pressure
devices
and so our illusion had a higher
concentration of dna so that's
really what we believe to be the the
main cause of the
increase in concentration and so
we did look at the quality of dna we
rented on gels
and not showing that data but it was it
was right on par with the
the positive refresher device and our
normal workflow so we believe the
quality of the dna was
was good and in the bottom right
figure i'm showing expression titers and
so what really matters at the end of the
day for us
is how the yields look when we take the
antibodies pure the dna that's purified
on these and we go into transfection and
look at
what the antibody yields are and so
black bars
are a couple replicate plates and then
uh
red purple and blue are the three
different vendors
uh positive pressure devices and there
is some variability in here but by and
large we have
run to run and play to play variability
uh
that's within this this degree
on our transfection system and so we
believe this you know the
the dna produced from these positive
rush devices
um was right in line with what we were
we were looking for and so it was nice
to see those results
and so we opted to go ahead and work
with some companies and
ended up working with beckman to design
a dna purification system
and so the first system that was
proposed
was a biomec i7 with two positive
pressure devices and they partner with
amplius
for these positive pressure devices
mounted off the side of a biomec i7
and then we have again platelock xpo
multi-flow for the reagent dispenses and
some bioshakes on the system as well
and we have a reader on here so as we
purify dna we can go
take a aliquot and measure it and
determine what the
purified yields are and so what became
apparent as we first designed this
system
and looked at what it would take to run
40 96 well minipreps on here
the what i mentioned earlier was we
started this process with 2096 well
plates of sorted cells and those get
split into heavy and light chain plates
and so that's where the 40 96 well
plates
are coming out of the system so when you
look at the plates that are coming in
the tip box is required to transfer
samples from the
e coli pellet deep well plate onto the
filter plates
the filter plates themselves illusion
plates
and tip boxes to transfer to make that
aliquot of eluded material
there's a lot of labware you can see
associated with
this process as well as looking at the
time
in the models of beckman was 11 and a
half or so hours just for the dna
purification side of things
and so this led us to start exploring
another bottleneck on here which is
all the lab word that we have to have on
this system
and so what we took a look at was the
thermos skyline that had come out right
around the time or just before the time
we were starting to design this system
and so this can be thought of like 14
pez dispensers and so
without having shelves and not you don't
have a random access like the the
standard cytomats you essentially can
stack up filter plates stack up your tip
boxes
and really have a high density storage
device on here
the other thing i mentioned is we have a
reader on here and we
are able to measure how much dna we've
made on here
well the next step is to normalize and
mix your heavy and light chain dna
and i'll talk about that in a little a
little later in the in the talk
but since we have the information on
here and we have a liquid a handler on
here
we have all the tools in place to be
able to do that mixing and so we modeled
that
up as well and so that's where you see
additional labware
on the right so we have another set of
tip boxes we have
the expressed the mixed dna plates which
should be 96 depot plates
and then we make an archive copy which
would be the 384 well copy with a small
amount of
dna and that's kind of like our
insurance policy if anything goes wrong
with the original plates that we've made
and so when we model the dna
purification with the mixing we're
looking at roughly a 20 hour
work of a 20-hour workday or 20-hour pro
automated process
to go from e-coli pellets all the way to
dna that's mixed and ready to be
transfected
and so that was a quite a
it doesn't leave a lot of time if you're
going to do this in subsequent days and
a lot of this is going to be running at
night and so
what we wanted to look at we're also
exploring a couple new devices on here
the positive pressure devices as well as
the
the thermocytomat skyline and so
to de-risk ourselves a little bit we
worked with beckman and
they had a nice proposal on upsizing
this system a little bit
so what we have here is with the final
system layout and it's another i7 with
two more positive pressure devices
and what you see are the skylines are
mounted directly
underneath the biomec i7s and with all
the labware that we're moving around
the robot movements start to become one
of the bottlenecks on here so by
mounting these skylines directly
underneath
and having the biomec pull tip boxes
and filter plates directly out of the
skyline and move them onto the deck
we're minimizing transport times and
speeding up the system significantly
and then having the redundancy of
essentially a mirrored
liquid handlers mirrored positive
pressure device and purification systems
on here
gives us a bit of an insurance policy as
we
you know anytime you're automating new
new types of instruments whether it be
the thermocyclers or the
the fragment analyzer you know there's
always unforeseen things after you go
through
uh you know a significant number of
samples over a couple years you start to
find where
what things work and what things are a
little bit uh
not as reliable or robust so by having
some redundancy on here
we really are are happy with that we
have some
insurance policy to keep the system
running at all time
and so we've put a balance on here as
well
the balances are throughout the systems
you'll see are really to do
some automated uh verification so as we
tell our liquid handlers to dispense a
certain volume or to transfer a certain
volume
we were weighing a lot of most of the
plates through our all our systems
before and after each of these steps and
this is uh
our qc step to make sure our liquid
handlers are holding up
as expected and so we have the positive
pressures in
place we have high density storage using
the new skylines
and so with the new model for this
system with some parallel processing
between the two
two wings of the system we can get the
purification down to a little over seven
hours and then
mixing in about four hours or so so this
is a
pretty reasonable for the number of
plates we're putting through the system
a little over 11 hours
for a full purification and mixture
so from there we go to
uh the protein expression system that
was developed a few years back with
fujifilm
or waco at the time now fujifilm and so
we take those 96 well plates with
normalized and mixed dna we put them
onto this
platform we add our transfection
reagents
and cells and then go into these cytomat
2c tower shakers and so these are
shaking incubators
and some of the nice features of this
system are we have four
cytomats that each have a 14 plate
capacity so 56 total plates can run on a
time
again when we develop this system these
tower shakers were
early days and so by having a bank of
four of them that's been a nice
insurance policy
where we've had issues that pop up from
time to time we're able to continue
running
typical runs are in the 20 to 40 plate
range so we're not using all four at a
time
uh for most runs and so this we're not
using all 56 positions or all four
cytomets
at a time and so we've been able to to
get by and keep our
our process moving forward by changing
the configuration of these on the fly
and using as many cinematics as needed
for a given day
when we go through our process we uh
right now i'm talking about a 96 well
process and we're doing
close to you know a little under one mil
expressions on this system
we eventually get to a point where we
triage these samples down and people
need more material and we'll purify
samples
and so what runs on here is not just 96
well plates but we also do
two and four mil transfections and
twenty four well plates
and those are all run in one run on here
in a
and based on the barcodes of the plates
the system will recognize whether
they're 24
well sampled 24 well plates with two
mills or four mil samples or 96 will
we call them one mil but they're they're
bit under one mil in total volume
and based on the barcodes the system
puts the plates on the
different liquid handlers to add
transfection reagents themselves
and it uses the barcode a suffix on the
barcode to determine what method to run
for that plate
so we treat all the plates as the same
and set the system up in an
identical manner and the system applies
different methods based
on the actual uh plate type it's running
so that's a nice feature of this system
and then we recently added a balance to
this system again
for automated liquid handling
verification and then there's a
dispenser on here for some reagents that
has a nice manifold system
so we have a very viscous solution on
on this as part of this workflow and so
it does an automated uh
clean up and washing of that dispenser
after hours
so that's a nice feature of this system
as well so our dna
gets put on here we add our transfection
reagents and cells
and typically the next day they're
getting pulled off of the system
and putting into put into cooner shakers
for roughly a little under a week
expression
and so as they come out of that weak
expression
uh then we put those plates with cells
uh that have been you know cho cells
typically expressing the material over
that
uh six to seven day timeline and then
we'll go on to what we call the
beckman quantum cherry pick system we
typically refer to this as our igg
system
and so the the workhorse instruments on
here are the
bionics high g centrifuges so these
are really nice centrifuges so if we
have different volume ranges
and the the rotor and the balance
tolerance for these center fuses are
are very excellent we can spin them at
very high speeds reliably and so
we've decided to upsize the centrifuge
on this particular system for those
for that reason so we have the bionics
high g centrifuges
we have a fleet of annexes on here so we
pellet the cells
on the in the centrifuge then we use the
biomec
nx's to transfer supernatant into a
fresh plate
and take a little aliquot of that into a
384 tilt welt plate compatible with the
octet
so we're one of the early folks
obviously with with beckman
in collaboration with forte bio to
integrate the octet htx
and so we we take the aliquot of the
supernatant put it on the octet htx
and use the octet to measure our titers
from the crude supernatants and then
that information
using some scripting that was developed
with
the beckman folks we are typically
setting a cutoff for what we call an
express sample and
around five micrograms per mil and then
we'll go to one of the other annexes and
then cherry pick samples that
are above that cut off and then leave
leave certain wells or a column empty
for controls for downstream assays
and so we're typically measuring tighter
on the octet
and then cherry picking and rearraying
the samples on another nx on the system
and again we'll we have a recent balance
on here
we have a barcode labeler so as we make
new plates we're
pinging our lymph system and then coming
up with new barcodes and
telling one system at the end of the
process what these new plates are where
the samples are and what concentration
material they have in them so it's a
really nice platform that's uh
that's been really one of the workhorse
systems for for this and several
processes
uh in our discovery efforts and then
i'll talk a little bit later
we recently put some bioshakes on here
and where that comes into play
so from this system we essentially have
supernatants
of a good amount of expressed material
that we're ready to start testing and so
what we have
uh in place and what we've had in place
was these plates that come off the
system and they're variable
concentration supernatants and these
values were determined on the octet
and then we would determine what our
screening plate
setup would be and we would typically
need to
normalize these variable concentration
samples using a lynx
which is a 96 variable volume pipetting
device
to a flat concentration say 25
micrograms per mil
and then from there we would go into
tempo
software that drives our echo access our
laptop access system
and make dose response plates that would
be used for screening
and so really the only reason that we're
doing this normalization step
is because the software that drove this
system
it was largely built for the small
molecule world and assumes that the
plates coming in
are all of a uniform concentration and
so we want to explore
options to go from a variable
concentration starting plate
to get to the same dose response plate
with a software-based solution so we
work with the folks at biocero
and incorporated their transfer map
workless generating software
and the scheduler green button go to
drive this system
to do exactly this so we can now take
the variable concentration supernatant
material
take the same type of dose response
plates and then generate
worklets and feed them to the echo to
accomplish this task and eliminate that
entire that normalization step
and so this is something that's been in
place for a good chunk of this year now
and it's been working nicely
so it's a nice example of a software
solution to really
streamline our our workflow a bit
so once we have our dos response plates
ready then one of our recent systems
late last year we affectionately called
the beast
and that's a a bit of a play on beckman
assay system and so it's a
the the drawing doesn't quite do it
justice but the scale is
far larger than all of our other systems
uh to give you a bit of a
flavor of the scale these this is a 1.5
meter
precise robotic rail on the right and on
the left it's a 2 meter rail
it's a fully enclosed system with 25
hepa filters on top
capable of running bsl 2 screens so i'll
start
kind of in the top left corner and go
around the system a bit
so we have two gnfwd2s they're mirror
images of one another
flanked by a couple of stack of mettler
balances again for liquid handling
verification i'll talk a little bit
about that
in a bit as well we have a suite of
liquid handlers
including the wd2s and we have a
certis over a combi as well as two blue
cat
blue washers and then we have again the
usual suspects
plate locks a4s sealers x peels on here
we have a couple biotech
spectrophotometer readers a multi-mode
reader from biotech as well the synergy
neo2
as well as a high throughput flow
cytometer the z5 from bio rad
and then we go around to a
biomac ic i7 and you'll see a couple
positive pressure devices off the side
of that and i'll talk about a little bit
later on
and the i7 is outfitted with the 96
multi-channel head and the span8 and
then we have the i5 that has a 3d4 head
on there
and then a couple cytomats typically
one's always at four degrees and one's
at 37 degrees
and so it's really you can see
most of the systems i've discussed thus
far are
built around doing a fairly fixed
workflow this is the kind of jack of all
trades where
we're going to run everything from
eliza's to cell-based assays to
high-throughput flow assays and
it's large and it has a lot of equipment
but you know no screen
incorporates all the equipment you
basically are looking at what you want
to accomplish with a specific screen
and applying the best tools for the job
and we have a lot of tools on this
system to be able to
to be able to accommodate any type of
assays our scientists would like to run
and one thing i want to talk a little
bit about is the
how the balances are incorporated onto
this system in particular
and so we have balances that work with
our wd-2s
to have a feedback loop to control
dispensing
so when we got this system early on
um we i put a bottle of
two liter bottle of pbs on to uh several
of the different types of dispensers on
this system and just dispensed 20
20 microliters per well into 3d floor
well plates and repeated that for
hundreds of cycles and what you see here
this is normalized to 20 microliters
and the theme of this is
basically all the dispensers drift over
time in a downward manner
the service and the wd-2 are using a
similar dispense mechanism where you're
pressurizing a bottle and opening up a
solenoid valve to dispense
and the combi is a peristaltic pump
driven dispense
mechanism but largely you can see the
same type of
downward trend over time this is
normalized and so the scale of this
you can see it's not a massive trend
over 100 to a couple hundred plates you
might only see a few percent difference
in volume
but that's something that we can be
aware of and that's something that we
can
control actually so i'll talk a little
bit about that
the other thing is having integrated
balances it's really an insurance policy
so if a bottle is an ice bucket and it
tips over
or if you run out of reagents you you
can factor in the crop
proper amount of dead volume we have
these systems notify us
and stop running and be able to have a
an operator intervene to fix something
and then to continue on
and so this is uh the balances are a
nice feature nice addition to the system
and so what we've done with with
uh beckman and other people have have
done this with other scheduler softwares
and integrated dispensers
as well is to have the feedback loop and
to have the software control dispense
volumes
so in the case of the wd-2s we are able
to
use that information feed it back to the
dispenser and as it drifts down
we it bumps it up and keeps it dead flat
for the course of a run
what i'm showing here is a another
reagent that we dispensed uh this is uh
this is actually filling up the the
octet um
the octet plates that would be on the
igg system with the with about 32
microliters of buffer
so the octet's typically a one to five
uh dilution of the supernatant so we
fill
32 microliters of a buffer and then
eight microliters of soup
and so here we're filling just a bunch
of plates to store in our refrigerator
for future runs
and as we this is early days with this
system late last year and and we were
sitting there
uh after the system set up and i was
showing the wd-2s to somebody
and they're talking about e-stops and
how to control the system
and how to respond to errors in the
system and and right after it finished
dispensing 32 microliters to the
11th plate i said well let's see it so
it finished dispense and i hit the e
stop right before it released the plate
to the robot
and so on the sami side of things
you get a pop-up that says do you want
to ignore the error do you want to retry
it
so just very quickly the user i was
working with
hit retry and so it already had 32
microliters per well in the 3d four well
plate
so he the retry is going to redo that
dispense
and so now you have 64 microliters per
well and so then he was going
around like oh we need to stop the
screen we need to fix things we'll start
it back up etc etc
pull them back and like no no this is
the beauty of what we just worked with
beckman to
build into the system watch the system
and just let it go
and so the next play obviously it thinks
it over overshot this dispense
and so the system undershoots the next
plate it over compensates a bit
and then within a few plates it dials
itself back onto setpoint and that's
kind of one of the
shows the power of this and so that was
i think he was pretty impressed to see
that and then using
this to show other folks of how we're
controlling things is a nice example of
it
obviously this is a gross example we
typically would not have
this much of a discrepancy in control
and oftentimes what people are going to
talk about with a feedback mechanism
like this well how can you catch a minor
clog or a single tip when you're using a
8-tip or several channel dispenser and
so
we determine the thresholds for what is
an error so usually
you are setting your thresholds fairly
tight around your set point and so if
if you do have one in eight tips clogged
you're going to be
you know 12 or so off in that dispense
volume
so if you're dispensing 20 microliters
you're going to want to stay
you want to probably keep that pretty
tight within a microliter so plus or
minus a microliter two
or maybe a couple microliters to be able
to catch those types of errors
and so this is something we're pretty
happy with and we
we like quite a bit and so
as we work with our scientists and we
get protocols to run different assays it
would typically be something
that looks like this this is a generic
protocol of dispensing cells incubating
doing a transfer further incubation
dispense
another incubate and read so what they
typically hand over to your scientists
is the reader data that comes off the
end of this
experiment what we're able to share with
our scientists now
is every one of these incubation steps
we have a gantt chart and we can show
timing and sami does that well as well
as several schedulers
but with the incorporated balances under
the system not only can we
show the gantt chart that we hit all the
timing points that they wanted
we can also say well you asked for 20
microliters 10 microliters of antibody
the detection reagent we can show
exactly
how much volume based on gravimetric
results
that these plates were receiving and so
if the data does
have certain trends in them or patterns
then we're able to go look at timing as
well as
uh dispenser performance to be able to
troubleshoot things
so it's a it's been a nice addition to
our systems
so this is a recent assay and so
we've done a lot of cover 19 work over
the the last few months
at lilly and and a big part of that is
running
significant number of eliza's on this
system and so
obviously this system would be very very
overkill if it were just performing
eliza's and that's why we have
so much equipment on here to do a bit
more complex work cell-based assays and
high-throughput flow cytometry
but this is a something the system's
been leveraged for and
it's been performing very well for us
over the past several months
and so a typical elisa process would be
you know do your wash and block transfer
samples
add your secondary substrate and then
the system we do several od
reads and that's one of the nice things
is we can do several reads because
the plates are always on there you have
a ballpark of
based on our sciences that we're working
with of how long it should take for
development time but
since we have all the plates on there
it's an automated fashion
we can read from just a few minutes out
to some of the plates we read at 18 plus
hours and so
it's it's nice to be able to just
essentially cue up the system
and let it go until these plates
saturate and then we back off and go to
the time point or a couple time points
before that
uh when we're looking at to try to get
good exposure without saturating
you do see a lot of steps in this
process for a somewhat basic eliza
and i would say that that is because of
all the way steps so every way step
is a node and then the script to analyze
the way step uh is another node and so
before and after all these liquid
handling steps you're seeing
a balance step followed by a script node
and so this
method is significantly larger than you
might see on another sami based system
and then one of the nice things we're
doing is our samples are coming off
in 96 well uh format and we're able to
use the biomec these ones are actually
being normalized on the links
prior to running the elyse's so we have
a flat concentration
of typically up to 96 samples in a 96
well plate
and then we're transferring into three
to four eliza plates and on the i7
we're doing a four point dilution so
we're able to run dose response plates
in a quadrant format in the going by
going from a 96 to a 3d4 well plate
and so we've generated results that look
something like this so the data coming
off the system
is we're using a dart report
to aggregate the data coming off the
system
and made spot fire templates that really
with
minimal touch points take that dart
report and drop it right into a spot
fire template
to be able to get what i would call kind
of the 10 000 foot view of our systems
and so
we're plotting row versus column and
trellising by plate
so this is two sets of plates a one
through eight and then what we're
calling b
one through seven so what i'm typically
doing here is
sizing by the od readout
and this is a 3d4 elisa plate and what
you can see is
let me zoom in here on one of these you
can see a nice titration of some
positive controls so there's controls in
the first column
and there are two fairly strong positive
controls and you see a nice titration
again these are sized by the od readout
you see towards the end of
the a plate and the last plate on the b
plates
there aren't any samples in this portion
and so it's nice to see
very consistent low sizing of the
squares
and then again i'm looking for streaks
edge effects other patterns that might
jump off the page to
indicate a liquid handler issue in the
system so this is really
not the final analysis but this is what
i would throw
data into a spot fire report like this
very quickly
or even as screens are running just to
be able to
see any trends and make sure that the
quality of the data is looking good
and then from this particular experiment
you know there are some
uh sledgehammer like really really
strong hits in uh
play a2 that ended up becoming important
for us later on
and so from from the system i'm really
trying to
hit home the point that the functional
highlights on here
we we can run eliza's very
wide variety in flavors of eliza
cell-based assays high-throughput flow
and then we can even prep plates for
offline instruments we have offline high
content imagers so we can do all the
washing stain
fixing staining of the plates on here
and seal them up and and prep them for
a high content in me is your imaging
based assay
and so it's it's been a nice uh a really
nice system
again kind of jack of all trades on here
and we've got a lot of equipment and
we've
really been focusing on lives the last
few months and so we're looking forward
to uh returning to work soon and
hopefully
getting more cell-based assays and we
late last year and early this year we
got a little bit of high-throughput flow
uh some high-tech flow cell binding
screens under our belts and so we're
we're excited to continue on that effort
we
can get back to some normal projects and
so
i touched on this whole process and
going from single b
cells to screening results to generate
lead molecules
but i mentioned a little bit earlier
when we're talking about the
transfection system is
you know this is all 96 well format
and the expression system we're doing
one mil samples
as we generate these leads and triage
that list down
the samples do feed back in here a bit
and we
increase we decrease the number of
samples but increase the volume and the
scale of those samples
and so we typically go into 20 foil
plates into four mil cultures
and at that point in time we're
typically not working with crude
supernatants when we're going for our
testing anymore we'd like to purify that
material
so early on uh last year
year and a half ago we were scoping out
a dna purification system
as well as a protein purification system
i think you can see here we
purify a lot of dna when we get to the
protein purification side of things
we've
down selected the number of samples
pretty significantly so
it took a step back and tried to justify
that
we should spend the money to upsizing
the dna system
and then do some small modifications on
our existing systems to enable the
protein purification side of things
and so that's where i'm going to talk
about those
those little tweaks that we've made
recently
and how we can enable the throughput
that we need for protein purification
and you know i've already shown why
we've and how we've upsized the dna
purification system
so kind of reallocating the money where
we get the best bang for our buck
and so this is the the the beckman quant
and cherry pick system again the
what we call the igg system and so as we
pellet cells and harvest the
supernatants and we measure the titer on
the octet
well we can do 24 we can run 24 well
plates in the system in
largely the same manner but what we can
also do is use
this the fleet of liquid handlers on
here
to add resin to those supernatants
and then we seal the plates up and then
put them on the bioshakes for roughly
30 minutes or so then what we would do
is
pellet that res pelt those those beads
with resin in the
high g centrifuge and then where you
typically
are having roughly four mils of sample
and resin in the plates at that point in
time
take off the you've pelleted the resin
so it's in a pallet at the bottom of the
well take off the
roughly three mils of supernatant
remaining on top of that so
what you have as an output of this
system is around one ml
of liquid and resin in these 24 well
plates and the
antibodies largely bound to the resin at
that point in time and we've done it
mike's done and my cohen's done a nice
experiment showing that we
are capturing nearly all of the antibody
in the supernatant
and so from here we can go to the dna
purification system where we
have the new i7 with a couple positive
pressure devices
and use the i7 to transfer those
roughly one ml of sample and the resin
into 96 well filter plates and then
use positive pressure the positive
pressure devices to push the sample
through the filter plates
do washing aleutian and then use the
biomic to make an aliquot
again read it on the integrated
spectrophotometer
and then have the i7 take a work list in
and
break out those samples by scientist or
request or a user
so from here we will
measure the amount of material and then
break the plates out and give people
plate maps of their purified material
so again you know putting a couple bio a
few bio shakes on another system and a
couple positive pressure devices on this
guy
and using all the other equipment that
we already have in place
really is a little bit of equipment to
enable a whole nother automated process
that we weren't doing previously
and so again this is the overview of the
process
and as i talked about in the very
beginning a lot of this is tied together
with
a lim's infrastructure and a lot of
folks have been
been helping on that front so it's a
huge effort not only to build these
systems with our team
and the collaborators such as beckman
and fujifilm and biocero
it's been a lot of work with the
informatics folks and the
it folks to develop the infrastructure
the limbs infrastructure for these
and so from this whole process and the
the whole reason why this all exists is
to really deliver
multi-species elisa data cell binding
flow data
functional cell by assay data and then
when we purify dna back on the
the dna purification system we do make a
cut for sequencing as well
and so by the time you have your
screening data coming off the right side
of this process
you you have sequencing results as well
to tie that back to
so it's really a rich data set to give
our scientists as much information as
possible
to whittle down our lead molecules
so with that again it's a really huge
effort i joined a couple years ago so
i'm
very thankful to have the pleasure of
sharing the work from the group
but this you know tom melissa and mike
had a huge role in this for several
years uh
before i got here and david lilian and
andrew are
are in my group and help with the
automation side of things as well
and so they've been everyone in my group
is
mike david liliana andrew are
responsible to support and keep these
systems running and work with the
beckman and the other vendors to improve
these systems and evolve them over time
and our scientists that carry out the
single cell process our screening group
as well as our sequencing folks you know
it's a huge amount of people in the
what we call the automation group all
underneath tom uh
that use these systems have suggestions
help evolve these systems and improve
them
and then the scientists we work with
upstream and downstream of us as well as
the
i.t folks have a huge role in this and
then we have several
uh labs managers that help support what
we do but we're very
thankful for it and the management
support to be able to build out this
infrastructure
and again our our the people we're
working with at beckman biocero and
fujifilm
to help develop these systems and to
continue to improve them over time
incorporating balances
integrating new devices as they come out
exploring new technologies and workflows
you know we have a lot of stuff to work
on
as we continue our process and look for
new opportunities to incorporate new
technologies
whether it be biology driven or
automation-driven so it's always
a never-ending cycle of improving these
guys
and so with that uh i'd like to thank
everyone for their time and
open it up for questions
thank you paul for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first question
is why not tr fret instead of alisa
uh thanks that so the question about
fret versus the elizas are you know we
we have a
lot of scientists here that have been
doing things a certain way for a long
time and so the
eliza's are kind of what we lean on and
i would say we have a vast amount of
expertise in the
allies area as well as the the costs
associated with them so they're fairly
inexpensive to run and we can develop
the assays very quickly
and we like i mentioned the
presentational that we run a variety of
formats from
image down to capture formats to
multi-species to 4.8 points replicates
and whatnot
so we we can develop these quickly and
deploy and run them in a very fast
manner with with minimal asset
development time and so
that's typically our our first pass is
going towards the license
thanks paul okay our next question this
is a two-part question
um says can you view information and
data in real time
and what are you using to push and pull
data to your different
systems yeah that's a really good
question
so it is uh system
and vendor specifics so on
uh several of the systems we have
scripts
uh where we are interacting with our
limb system where
we can work with the vendor in some
instances on a lot of the beckman
systems where we can
ping our limb system to gather
what information is is what samples and
concentrations and
and other data for those plates that are
coming onto the system
the system can process plates do
transfers
uh run screens and then when it's
typically done
it will use the it also has scripts to
push information back to limb system to
say
samples move from this barcode well on
this plate to this new play and now this
is
data associated with those samples and
so
uh several of our systems have have
things set up that way whether they're
from the
the bioserious side of things beckman
side of things or
uh the fujifilm side of things so we
kind of are working with the vendors
on each platform to accomplish the task
of
integrating with our lens systems
and then the part about yeah sorry the
second part of that was
looking at data in real time and so
the main ones we're looking at real time
are
actually all the beckman systems and
that's where we're using dart so that's
the
uh basically a database and a nice gui
that sits on top of the systems to be
able to
look at what's running on the platforms
and that's more in a table format and so
what i talked about on the assay system
is i'm taking that dart report
and then trying to get that into a
visualization platform like spotfire
it's kind of what i tend to lean on and
so
we're trying to marry those two things
so being able to very simply create dart
reports and have a lot of pre-defined
dart reports and i can export and link
right into spot fire templates that i've
created to get a quick view either
during runs and
after runs especially as well
thanks paul okay your next question what
different
b-cell screening approaches do you use
um that's probably a more upstream
question
than i might be able to answer so
we have several types of species and we
have
um developed
different immunizations like animal
based immunization strategies
we have uh as i mentioned a number of
other types of uh
antibody discovery platforms not just
b-cell discovery platforms so
i don't know if i can go too much into
the different
platforms upstream of us very much in
this talk
thank you now this user wants to know is
scp
safe um
i'm not exactly sure what they mean by
scp
right so um let me see
let's see if this user if you want to go
ahead and just retype your question and
maybe elaborate a little bit more we'll
try and get to it before the end of the
presentation
um but for now let's go ahead and move
on to this next question
how do you analyze complex data sets
such as
flow cytometry data
yeah that's a that's a really good
question so the the dart reports are
really helpful
for taking reader data that's kind of a
flat file coming off the system when you
have something
significantly more complex like flow
cytometry data
that's where we need to develop a
different type of
work stream to be able to use
third-party software such as flow joe
to be able to take the data coming off
the system
process it in flowjo and then pop it
into something like spotfire to
visualize your results
and so that's where basically
written a script to uh streamline that
process so if we have a flow joe
template
flowjo can be rerun from a command line
and so
essentially you can write a script to
point flow joe to all the data
and to feed fojo a plate at a time
and consolidate all those results into
one
large csv file and then that's the
process data that you can then put into
spot fire or downstream analysis tool
set
so it's basically another instance where
we
kind of had to create a little
intermediate tool to
take the data coming off the system and
get it into an analysis
platform like flowjo to be able to
properly process the data
and then be able to put it into a
visualization and downstream
tool that our scientists are comfortable
with using
okay we have time for a few more
questions let's go with this one
what additional system or systems do you
feel would be compliant with this
workflow
or yeah to complement the workflow i
think they were
uh meaning uh so oh sorry yes
complimentary it's okay
yeah that's all right um so what we
have on this whole platform we i we're
i don't know that we're going to build
out several or any more new big systems
i think we want to look at ways to
leverage the existing system so i talked
about
enabling protein purifications with some
fairly
small upgrades to the existing platforms
so i don't know that there's going to be
a lot of hardware changes i think
software is really where we're going to
be able to gather a lot more information
on there we have balances
on a lot of the systems we are
we put in a camera system late last year
to basically have eyes on all these
systems and
i think one thing that was interesting
with that the first night we installed
the camera system we caught a
bug on a system that is very
infrequently occurring
and we were able to take the data logs
from the system as well as the video and
hand to a vendor
to show them that you know this is what
the software is telling
is reporting and this is what is
actually happening with with cameras and
so
deploying cameras balances capturing
more data
we want to look at every system and try
to find where the weak points are and
make them more reliable
as well as try to look to continue to
find software solutions to be able to
streamline our process
and and make things more efficient so
you know we
may not build a new big system um i
would say
one thing that kind of would help feed a
lot of these systems would be
uh some automated tissue culture we have
a selectee that's quite old and
you know that might be a one system that
would really help complement what we're
doing here
so we're thinking about that but we we
have
no plans right now to to be able to pull
the sugar on any of that
and so we yeah i think that's the main
thing that we're looking at is
possibly something in that space but a
lot of what we're doing is going to be
more on the software side of things
all right we have time for just one more
question
where do you see these automated
platforms going over the next
one to two years yeah that's a good
question so we've been working on
on the limb side of things significantly
so connecting these more
getting things streamlined so even our
standalone biomix i talked about the
transformation step largely be a manual
process so
hooking up a lot of our standalone
equipment getting barcode readers on
there and connecting the standalone
equipment and the integrated systems all
to our lims platform
and then you know i don't know where
things will happen if there's ever
a possibility of connecting the systems
and somehow
uh you know mobile robots and things
like that that have been talked about
the soas conference this might be an
opportunity to leverage things like that
that would be much further down the road
but we have a lot of islands here and
a lot of the touch points in between the
islands are typically storing plates in
four degree refrigerators so i would say
at some point in time you can envision a
process like this there there might be a
way to connect them with a mobile
robotic platform
but that's pretty far down the line i
think not in the next year or two thank
you paul
um do you have any final comments for
our audience before we close out today
uh no i just want to you know thank the
the vendors we've been working with
and uh you know a lot of people in the
automation group
like i mentioned i've been here a couple
years and so there's a there's a lot of
people that have been working on this
for
for several years before i i joined and
uh it's been a pleasure to work with
everyone and
hello on the lilly side and on the
beckman and biocero and fujifilm side as
well
great well thank you so much for your
time today and for your research
we'd also like to thank labruz and our
sponsor beckman culture life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for today and for their
interesting questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care bye
thank you